from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Red Bull and the UK and the US
this is food Wars
in the UK Red Bull comes in three
portion sizes a 250 milliliter can
a 355 milliliter can and a 473
milliliter can in the US our Red Bull
cans come in four
sizes 0.4 fluid ounces or 250
milliliters 12 fluid ounces or 355
milliliters 16 fluid ounces or 473
milliliters and the biggest one 20 fluid
ounces
yo or
591 milliliters that means our us
largest size is 30 percent bigger than
the UK's
if we're actually getting our 473
milliliters worth
actually looks slightly more than 473.
maybe we're getting even more for our
money the largest single item by volume
in the UK is a 24 pack of our 355
milliliter cans that totals 8 520
milliliters which is around 288 fluid
ounces while we do have a larger cannot
offer that only comes as part of a 12
pack meaning that the total is only 5
664 milliliters Which is less than the
24 pack of this one in the US our
largest mobile item is a 24 pack of 12
fluid ounce cans I wasn't able to get my
hands on it
but is the same liquid amount as the
UK's largest our closest second is a 12
pack of 24 fluid ounce cans
hero all the Red Bull products you'll
find in the UK some of which you won't
find in the US here are all the Red Bull
items in the U.S you won't find in the
UK so technically we have eight Red Bull
products in the UK we have the normal
one we have the sugar-free one we have
the zero one red green yellow orange and
white some of these are seasonal and
we'll rotate in and out so it's a little
bit tricky to keep track of exactly
what's on offer but this is what we
could get today in addition to this we
have a couple of sugar-free exclusives
which technically adds to the total from
what I can tell these three flavors are
exclusive to the US and you can't find
them in the UK first we have the blue
Edition which is blueberry flavored and
we got the peach flavored which I
believe is flavored Peach and the winter
Edition which is what flavored fig Apple
now both countries have the coconut
flavor but from what I can tell online
we also have the coconut sugar free
flavor I actually couldn't even find
sugar-free versions of the red one or
the orange one I did find a sugar-free
yellow one though you can tell it's
sugar-free because it's got this blue
sugar-free band there
blue sugar-free label there and also the
tab is blue that's quite fun well it's
not technically a UK exclusive I did
find this one while I was hunting for
Red Bull I think it's imported from
Thailand and it's a cold brew coffee
flavored Red Bull which sounds pretty
intense because there aren't too many
exclusives between the US and the UK I'm
gonna do a lightning round of every
flavor I can get my hands on here in the
US couldn't find any of the sugar-free
option but I know they are available at
least online and also I got Red Bull
Zero and sugar-free Red Bull so let's do
a quick Lightning Run of each flavor
ready the issue here is that I don't
drink energy drinks I don't like the
taste of Red Bull they make me feel
weird I drink tea if I need a bit of a
caffeine here and that's it but
apparently I have to taste test all of
these so wish me luck
I am not happy about this
regular Red Bull flavors but uh
sugar-free
I don't think I've ever had a sugar-free
one maybe I should because I did drink
an alarming amount of Red Bull when I
was younger and maybe a sugar-free
option would have been a good idea
well side-by-side action
regular
sugar-free I might start getting the
sugar-free ones it's like really close
good job on that Red Bull
basically the only time I drink Red Bull
is when it's in a Jager Bomb
it's also
makes me think of those which is not the
vibe for a 11AM video shoot
cheers I guess so this is the normal Red
Bull
the best thing I can say about this is
that The Taste kind of like disappears
fairly fast
so I'll uh
leave that in the middle to begin with
while I did the rankings
this is the sugar-free version
in the giant can
the aftertaste isn't quite as nice with
the sugar-free version
slightly worse than the regular one
sugar-free
has some sugar in I guess it says zero
grams of sugar and sugar-free but for
some reason they got another one they
had zero sugar
okay
it doesn't have much of a taste either
to be honest you get kind of like that
like energy drink like jolt you get when
you take a sip of an energy drink
the Ripple zero oddly doesn't have that
okay the coconut Edition coconut Berry
Red Bull
I've never seen a human being drink any
of these never in my life have I seen
anyone purchase one of these or drink
them up until me making this video I did
not know this existed
and I don't know why they exist still
let's find out all right coconut and
Berry Red Bull
the product nobody asked for
this coconut Berry Red Bull is
absolutely terrible that is absolutely
that is what it's like to drink
uh sunscreen
red one watermelon
I actually don't hate that
that's not bad
my issue is I don't understand why they
settled on that as the taste of like
unsweetened unflavored Red Bull because
it's not good
at least in my opinion watermelon has
helped that out the green addition the
dragon fruit as you are aware dragons
are green so clearly the can is green
dragon fruit ever to make that
connection
oh my God
it's somehow worse than this one it's
somehow worse
this is what I think pea tastes like
does that make sense it smells like pee
the energy that Red Bull gives you
is being counteracted by the absolute
depression these flavors are giving me
right now I'm like having this weird
thing about all this energy and it's
being converted into sadness because of
these two next up is the green one which
is flavored with cactus fruit
I don't know what cactus fruit is meant
to taste like if I saw a green can I
would assume maybe green apple or lime
it's fine I don't think it's quite as
good as the watermelon
watermelon Red Bull uh I don't want to
do this anymore
we're making a comeback watermelon's not
bad
watermelon's not bad
oh yeah baby the Red Bull meter is going
up
sugar-free tropical fruits
I generally quite like tropical fruits
flavored things because I have a palette
of a child
I spoke too soon that's really gross
no bad worst one so far worse than the
sugar-free normal one all right blue
Edition
blueberry
tart wow tart
38 grams of sugar in this you would not
think you would not believe that in the
way this tastes
I guess not complaining it's just do you
want your energy drink to be tart
regular tropical fruits one thing I'm
already noticing is that the sugar-free
versions have much less of a strong
smell compared to the versions with
sugar it's better than the sugar-free
version
still not great
the regular tropical version is actually
better than unflavored Red Bull whereas
the sugar-free one something's gone
wrong there because that is actually
worse than the classic red bull all
right Peach Edition Peach nectarine here
we go
[Music]
yeah wow
oh that's good that's really good also
tart
38 grams of sugar
the summer edition apricot strawberry I
mean that sounds lovely this maybe
sounds like the most appealing of any of
them so far so I've got high hopes
smells pretty good I get I get notes of
strawberry
[Music]
oh
okay
see this is concerning uh because I
didn't actually want to like any of
these this is a problem guys I can't
become a rebel guy I'm not ready for a
Red Bull era
I'm too loyal to Mercedes
this is pretty good
I definitely like I get apricot and
strawberry from that
it's not overpowering
it's just like a sort of nice Sparkle
River that's yeah that's the best one
I've tried so far
winter Edition fig Apple
fig Apple winter I'm not making the
connection
[Music]
um
foreign
apple Jolly Rancher was a drink does
that make sense
no not refreshing at all the coconut and
Berry Edition
I'm not getting much if any of the berry
flavor from this
Coconut's definitely the uh the star of
the show but it's not bad coming from
someone who like I say doesn't usually
like coconut as a flavoring I think it's
actually it's better than the tropical
as far as I'm concerned and last on the
flavor train we got the yellow Edition
tropical ooh tropical
oh it doesn't smell very good just
please be at least
[Music]
yeah okay
yeah it's all right okay and then last
but by no means least we have this
random imported coffee one that I found
my only concern or I guess comment on
this one is that I'm not sure who the
target audience is because I feel like
if you like coffee you'll just drink
coffee if you want a caffeine hit I'm
not sure why if you liked coffee you
would want to flavor your Red Bull with
coffee because you're already getting
the caffeine but here you're just
getting like loads of sugar and
additives as well
it tastes like someone has taken
a coffee and poured Coca-Cola in it
which
might be to your liking it's the spot
the I want to Jack my caffeine level
through a roof spot I actually where
would that go is that better than
regular red bull
[Music]
if you don't think it is
but is it the worst one I've had today
[Music]
no no it's not that's there
that's there
and we're done
my vision is starting to blur
oh uh this might this might have been a
bad idea oh no no
it's kicking in
I like Red Bull sugar-free is exactly
the same thing this one had less of an
aftertaste which actually I didn't
really like coconut and dragon fruit
uh suntan lotion NP uh watermelon I
liked
blue a little too tart Peach
I enjoyed fig Apple trash
and a tropical not bad my main takeaways
from that uh firstly I need to lie down
we can make that happen that would be
great secondly I think the sugar-free
versions are overwhelmingly like worse
tasting than the sugar versions are I
also think for me like I say I don't
love the taste of just normal Red Bull
so I think I've ended up liking the ones
which are flavored with things which
aren't Red Bull so that makes sense
[Music]
what about the price one in the UK a 250
milliliter can will cost you one pound
fifty at a Tesco Supermarket that works
out to roughly 60 Pence per 100
milliliters which is around 74 cents in
the US the cost of this 250 milliliter
Red Bull can at Walmart is two dollars
and eighteen cents which breaks it down
to 80 cents per 100 milliliters so it
looks like the UK is actually getting a
slightly better deal on its Red Bull
than the US's that's actually kind of a
food Wars first so it doesn't happen
often
in the UK our standard Red Bull contains
the following ingredients water sucrose
glucose acidifier citric acid taurine
sodium carbonates and magnesium
carbonate caffeine niacin pantothenic
acid vitamin B6 vitamin B12 flavorings
colors caramel and riboflavin and carbon
dioxide our Red Bull in the U.S contains
pretty much the same stuff carbonated
water sucrose glucose citric acid
taurine sodium bicarbonate magnesium
carbonate caffeine
calcium
[Music]
Pantheon Tate
pyroxtonite HCI
vitamin B12 natural and artificial
flavors all right the vitamins have
different names but it's all the same
you might notice the ingredient taurine
on that list now taurine has been the
subject of inaccurate rumors on the
internet for years taurine has an
association with Bulls drawing its name
from the Latin word for bull Taurus some
people run with this and firstly claim
that it's code for bull semen the name
actually comes from the fact that
taurine was first isolated from oxbial
okay the good news is that there's no
oxfit in Red Bull as food producers have
used a synthetic version of taurine that
isn't derived from animals also means
that Red Bull is suitable for vegans one
study found that exposing human teeth to
energy drinks for 15 minutes four times
a day resulted in a significant and
irreversible loss of tooth enamel the
study also noted that energy drinks were
twice as harmful as regular soft drinks
to tooth enamel as the study in rats
found chronic intake of Red Bull may
cause a decline in kidney function
however these results have not been
replicated in human studies but any
excuse to see my boys are dancing rats
Rebel in the UK contains 110 calories
per 250 milliliter can one of these cans
also contains 27 grams of sugar
according to their website this is
actually a similar amount of sugar to
what you might find in say apple juice
both sugar-free Red Bull and Red Bull
Zero contain 10 calories per this 8.4
fluid ounce can sugar-free fully
sugar-free replace their sugar with
acid flame potassium and aspartame Red
Bull Zero Place sugar with
acetyl-fin potassium K and Sucralose
that's the sulfame potassium or SK which
is Red Bull's zero calorie sweetener has
had its share of controversy over the
years although to be fair a lot of the
studies this came from were done in the
1970s this has led to their validity
being called into question in recent
years according to healthline.com in
1996 the Center for Science in the
public interest urged the FDA to do more
testing on acek before allowing its
inclusion in soft drinks the cspi go on
to say that there are health concerns
associated with ask including cancer
hormone disruption and risks to pregnant
people
was also study that determine the
chronic use of acek and male mice was
linked to possible changes in brain
function over a period of 40 weeks yeah
I believe that it's been 40 minutes and
my brain is just
one of the perceived benefits of
drinking Red Bull is that it's supposed
to give people a boost through its
caffeine content a 250 milliliter can
contains 80 milligrams of caffeine but
is that a lot compared to other soft
drinks yeah a 12 ounce can of Coke
contains 34 milligrams of caffeine
that's less than half the amount of
caffeine and almost double the amount of
fluid as this Red Bull a 12 ounce can of
Mountain Dew contains slightly more with
55 milligrams if we compare Red Bull to
another popular energy drink Monster
you'll find that they actually have the
same caffeine content per 100
milliliters which is 32 milligrams
although monster cans tend to be bigger
so you are getting more caffeine in
total the caffeine amount however can be
a bit underwhelming when compared to
regular coffee and eight ounce 237
milligram brewed coffee contains on
average 95 milligrams of caffeine and a
double shot of espresso contains 125
milligrams one issue comes from the fact
that some people will consider Red Bull
to be more like a soda and therefore
might drink higher quantities of it so
is it possible to overdose on Red Bull
uh yeah although highly unlikely
caffeine-related dads have been found in
individuals that intake somewhere
between three and five grams not
milligrams grams of caffeine in one day
that would be 40 of these I feel like
your bladder would explode first
although apparently that wasn't enough
caffeine for some people in 2014 Red
Bull were sued in a class action lawsuit
around false advertising remember the ad
campaign Red Bull gives you wings well
it doesn't false advertisement back then
Red Bull did say in its marketing they
that this drink could improve
concentration and reaction speeds a
claim that lacked any scientific support
furthermore the suit said that Red Bull
persistently and pervasively Market
their product as a superior source of
energy worthy of a premium price over a
cup of coffee or other sources of
caffeine Red Bull did agree to a 13
million dollar settlement which granted
anyone who purchased a Red Bull dating
back to January 1st 2002 was entitled to
10 or 15 worth of Red Bull
it looks and sounds exactly like P
uh
good morning